this olympian broke down during her
isolation after being infected with
kovid i'm
not sure if i can
handle
14 more days at the olympic
competition
about being in this isolation
covid19 and strict social distancing
restrictions within the beijing loop
have made the 2022 winter games a major
challenge for athletes already under
immense pressure to perform their best
after years of training
over 180 athletes and team officials
tested positive after arriving in
beijing since january 4th and had to go
into isolation raising concerns of
mental health
team usa figure skater vincent joe
withdrew from the games after testing
positive
i have been doing everything in my power
to stay free of cove since the start of
the pandemic i've taken all the
precautions i can i've isolated myself
so much that
the loneliness i felt in the last month
or two has been crushing at times
isolation is not good for anybody and i
understand the frustration the stress
the disappointment that they feel after
all the preparations and that's why we
develop the protocols to allow as many
people out of isolation as possible the
reality however is i can't make the
pandemic go away for the duration of the
games
one of the best parts of the olympics is
typically the camaraderie the
interactions we have with our fellow
competitors and fellow athletes from
other countries and even that's been uh
limited and without that type of release
we're going to see the pressure cooker
build and build and build as athletes
are often left to struggle with their
own thoughts behind closed doors in
their own rooms
as athletes you know we train our
spiritual body our emotional body and
our physical body constantly
and then when it's taken away from you
that's something that's not even your
choice that's a pretty big bummer
kirka says kofit has affected athletes
like him in a lot of different aspects
from training to daily outlook he's
flying to beijing later this month to
compete at the winter paralympics in
march
i am concerned going to beijing and
catching kovid and not getting to
compete because so much of my life right
now there's there's a lot of pressure
and like the whole world's on my back uh
going into the games and to catch
coveton to not get a chance to compete
when i've been training for years for a
single moment would really be a bummer
well it's very important to use
electronic media for us to be able to
connect with loved ones so the more we
could zoom and facetime and skype with
uh fellow people back home that love and
support us that's gonna be really really
necessary i think it's vital that they
also have an outside in head process of
what book are they reading on the mind
on mental health
what can they do from the external to
internalize
that kind of information that's really
going to help them be the best version
of themselves emotionally
beijing 2022 and another olympics under
kovid has put a renewed spotlight on
mental health in athletes
i mean i think that it really has become
normalized
with so many athletes talking about
their mental health and i think there
has been such a push for parody with uh
mental health and physical health so i
think the conversation is going to
continue and i i hope really grow
[Music]